الى اسرائيل واصدقاء عوده بنيامين نتنياهو
لسلطه في اسرائيل لم تقتصر على الداخل فقط
فهي تسمع الان في الداخل الايراني ايضا
كيف لا وهو الذي توعد قبل رحيله الاخير
وحتى قبل مجيئه الحالي بان سياسته تجاه
ايران كعدوا لن تتغير ابدا وان برنامجها
النووي سيكون هدفا دائما والان وبعد عودته
يفكر نتنياهو
بخطط لاتخاذ اجراءات ضد المنشات النوويه
خلال فتره ولاياتها المقبله بينها ضرب
وتدمير تلك المنشات ومنع واشنطن من
التواصل الى اتفاق النووي مع طهران وفقا
لصحيفه
اجراءات ردع اسرائيلي لابد منه ان يتخذها
امام الاستسلام وامامه امتلاك ايران
المحتمل لسلاح النووي وهو الامر طبعا الذي
تواعد زعيم اللكود فيها لطهران قبل ايام
بانه لم يحصل مهما كلف الامر لكن هناك
ايضا ادوات اخرى قد يتخذها نتنياهو ايقافه
البرنامج مثل الهجوم عن بعد او الهجمات
السبرانيه او خطط التخريب واغتيال عملاء
طهران النوويين مثل النوع الذي نصيب الى
اسرائيل في الماضي مهامه يا هولندا تنتهي
عند منع ايران من امتلاك سلاح نووي اذا ان
هناك ثمه تهديد ايراني على الحدود تماما
وهو وجود ميليشيات طهران في سوريا
وتواهلها على الحدود فمن ذو بدء الاحداث
في سوريا في العام 2011 كان الشاغل الاكبر
لتل ابيب هوبح جماح المحاوله المستمر من
قبل ايران للانشاء البنياتها التحتيها
العسكريه في سوريا وتدمير طرق امداد ميليش
حزب الله من صواريخ مواجهه بدقه ويرجح
طبعا ان يعود نتنياهو لتباع هذه السياسه
مجددا بل تعزيزها ايضا برفع وتيره القصف
الجوي والصاروخي لسوريا خصوصا وانها خفت
من بعثته ولا يستبعد مراقبه اسرائيليون
تواغلا بريا محدودا لمنع اقتراب من
الشائران الحدود الاسرائيليه
[موسيقى]